[Music]
the feeling that you have when you spend
15 minutes trying to open a lock and you
feel the barrel moving and you heard the
click
the reward you got it's incredible
[Music]
this is dominic vellner he is a cyber
security director an ethical hacker a
preacher and a lock picker
ethical hacker is someone who hacks
systems but for the good reasons
so finding vulnerabilities finding way
that hackers can exploit and patch it
and make things a little bit more safer
normally an attack will start by
phishing email and we have to react very
very fast
very stressful but very funny at the
same time every day is different you
have to learn as fast as the hackers and
make things more secure
when he's not at his day job of
preventing cyber security breaches he is
in his basement picking locks
i started lock picking
more than 40 years ago
lock picking is my hobby it relaxes me
no matter if it's an electronic clock a
physical lock a door lock as soon as i
can get a lock i'm trying to to open it
the tools that i'm using are mainly
lockpicks
and sometimes i'm using 3d printers to
reproduce key
[Music]
a year and a half ago i found a very
huge vulnerability on
high security lock and those locks are
used in many many businesses and i find
a way to open it with a zip tie under
three seconds so normally operate with a
key or keypad so i will just insert a
zip tie with some hook in it that i have
made
there's a little entry here by the drain
hole
the hook is going inside
hooking the little black arm
and now it's open
simply as that
and i reach out to the company i say hey
guys i i find a vulnerability you know
you must do something and now it's a
year and a half and there's millions of
luck vulnerable right now on the field i
think they have to learn something from
that and that's why i will make
the hack public so they have to react
this is the fix i developed we called it
the tie breaker and it's super easy to
install just push it into the drain hole
and there you go make it way more secure
ethical hacking is just not about our
work it's
the way that we live i must report this
kind of big vulnerability because if i
can find it
bad people can find it too
it's the same thing
fighting an attack and
winning and opening luck at the end of
the day is the same reward that you
you have and i think ethical hacking
ethical lock picking is not just about
open opening locks
my goal is to make it more secure not
only my my enterprise my business but
also you know the world
[Music]
you